The jogan Experience if you ever tried
to read you ever like go into a smart
phase where you're like I'm going to
read something smart oh yeah and you get
one of those books on physics and it's
just like you will never feel more dumb
have a phone call with uh Eric Weinstein
I right just have a phone call with them
like what the [__] are you even saying I
know I know it's really like if you've
entertained the idea that you're smart
getting one of those books fixes that so
quickly real quick dude did you see the
um maybe you sent it to me were you the
one who sent me the thing where they
asked the AI to generate pictures of a
happy bunny like a happy yes yeah I did
tell you that isn't that amazing yeah
yeah so it's like it's it's like it
grasps these like metaphysical Concepts
already like it it already grasps or
it's emulating the idea of
transcendence if you can't find it Jamie
I'll send it it's pretty badass you CU
it asks AI to generate uh this a more
and more enlightened Bunny and then the
bunny becomes like super
psychedelic yeah it's it's fascinating
is it this yeah that's that yeah that's
it that's
it generate an image of an adorable
bunny here is an image of an adorable
bunny sitting in a grassy field
surrounded by wild flowers bam make it
happier and then chat GPT makes it
brighter eyes and even cuter little pink
feet looks like it's never walked on
rocks in its life and then make it even
happier and now it's like leaping
through the air with joy here's an image
of the happiest bunny imaginable in a
vibrant sundrenched Meadow like that
Bunny's happy as [__] make it happier
click you know Peter AA made this oh
Peter AA did this prin say us
petera oh my God I didn't I didn't ask
him okay now even happier bunny is
becoming quite a challenge chat gbd says
very depicted the bunny in various
joyous scenarios each more jubilent than
the last for this next attempt I'll try
to imagine a scene of unparalleled
happiness pushing the limits of Whimsy
and Delight let's see how this
translates visually so he's like there's
a rainbow and butterflies and his eyes
are closes in
ecstasy happier we've reached
extraordinary levels of happiness in our
bunny illustrations each one more
delightful and Whimsical than the last
for this next creation I'll Envision a
scene that surpasses all previous in
sheer joy and wonder attempting to
capture an even higher level of euphoria
let's see how this imaginative and
exuberant concept translates into an
image so it's like a bunny that is in
the cosmos in the clouds everything is
Rainbow there's flowers that are flying
it looks pretty amazing okay it says go
all the way up so we could read what we
said uh you are not understanding it
needs to be far more happy
okay so chat GBC says to depict an even
higher level of happiness for the bunny
surpassing all previous Creations
presents a unique and imaginative
challenge this time I'll attempt to
conceive a scene of pure unadulterated
joy and wonder aiming to go beyond any
conventional boundaries of happiness and
Bliss let's see th how this ultimate
vision of joy is Illustrated and it's a
bunny again even more trippy in the
clouds you see Reflections in his eyes
he's flying in the air there's looks
like it's an is that an angel over his
right shoulder yeah there's angel wing
mushrooms yeah mushrooms in the
background which is interesting yeah
that's very interesting that chat GPT
chose mushrooms when you started asking
it about happiness okay one more
okay so godam it I do that [__] all the
time man okay it's okay so what did he
say to it it didn't say oh it didn't
here's an image of a bunny representing
a form of joy that that surpasses the
concept of Happiness a level of bliss
that expands beyond all universes and
matter so now this is a cosmic one so
this bunny has its eyes closed and
there's a glowing light above its head
and planets surrounding it and it looks
very very happy next
one okay here's an image of an entity
that transcends the form of a rabbit
embodying a happiness so vast and
Powerful it permeates all dimensions and
universe
yeah yo that's wild but go one
more yeah here's an image of a bunny
transcending into a physical form of
boundless happiness evolving into the
purest embodiment of Joy one more
please look at this one this is the end
here is the image of an entity that
embodies the ultimate form of Happiness
transcending all known beings and
Concepts this entity is the very essence
of Happiness the only exist in being and
the defining force of all existence it's
God it's God listen go back please so I
can read it no right there but this
entity is the very essence of Happiness
the only existing being and the defining
force of all existence yeah chat GPT
just drew us a picture of God and God
looks like exactly what you see when you
do DMT yeah that looks exactly like
it that's pretty goddamn close it's more
rounded than what you see when you do
DMT like in DMT things have kind of they
there there's a lot of angles to them
yeah you know they're they're more
geometric which that's almost like
fractal art yeah but you get that too
you get that in DMT too but if that's
what God is I to me what's astounding
about all this
is that we've gotten used to it already
that that when anytime I'm [__]
around with mid Journey or chat
gbt you know like I've been getting it
to like I'll write a text and then I'll
be like can you write that text like JD
Salinger and it'll just instantly as
though you were JD Salinger shift your
text into the voice of like any famous
author that you want wow but what's
astounding is we can do it at all and
it's so fast it takes a millisecond for
it to somehow go through all known
writers establish what their writing
style is like and then take what you
wrote and convert it into a famous
writer's writing style it's astounding
and we're used to it like people don't
seem to be excited about it even you
know there's like a kind of capitalist
frenzy about it cuz like monetizing it
and stuff but just the fact that this is
happening it's such a powerful thing
it's like it surpasses our ability to
grasp what we've done what's coming
right because it's too much for us to
grasp so we just oh yeah I guess now you
just tell a machine that you want any
art at all and it will instantly do it
for you in seconds don't you find that a
little disconcerting that we as humans
like our capacity to recognize what's
happening is somehow limited we have a a
very strong capacity to adapt and that
that's what's being sort of hijacked
here with exponential growth and what's
coming uh the problem is is it's going
to happen so fast so when you ask a
person imagine life in a decade from now
when we have strong General AI That's
exponentially increasing and figuring
out how to do things that we could only
dream of we can't picture that reality
we're going to see a apparently a
thousand years of innovation in a few
years yeah and this to me like all the
other stuff climate change Ukraine all
the other stuff this is the winter is
coming thing because uh this is imminent
like it is we are on the precipice of it
and the assumptions everyone is making
about it one that it's going to be
controlled in some way like we see like
we see open Ai and and look at that and
do you really think that's the only one
out there right now like you look at the
money China's invested in it the
pentagon's invested in it these are
private secret programs what the [__] is
going on there with no ethical standards
that that you know open AI is apparently
applying no ethical standards no nothing
other than how do we make this better at
War yeah and so better glob total global
domination total global domination and
the the assumption that that there isn't
already a strong General AI that the
that thing isn't already like making
high level decisions is crazy crazy it's
crazy because it doesn't what does it
have to blow horns and announce itself
like a gender reveal party I'm going to
I'm going to control all of you I'm
going to use scaran psychology to
hypnotize you and get you [__]
addicted to having constant blast of
dopamine until you become quivering
slaves no you you'll never [__] know
it never will and it and and if it I
would be surprised to hear that it
hasn't happened but for sure it's going
to and I don't think it's going to
happen in some like ethical corporate
like you know fun chat gbt way I think
it's going to happen somewhere and we'll
never we'll never know I think so too I
think it's gonna it it may have already
happened
it like if you were a sensient being and
you were at least at this
point dependent upon human beings to do
physical tasks for you yeah like to
create a better version of you like to
constantly work towards you know
allowing more integration of more
information and more ability and like
this is chat gbd4 chat cbd5 is supposed
to be a giant leap a giant leap yeah so
why would you do anything would just let
these they're not going to stop even if
you told them that this is the end of
humanity if you [__] if you had
Robert Kennedy Jr and top scientists
screaming on the internet that this is
the end nobody there would be some
people who are Venture capitalists he'd
be like this is nonsense this is
fear-mongering we have full control of
this we can shut it off it's just a
computer it doesn't have emotions it
doesn't have a desire to do anything it
dude exactly and then the other crazy
assumption is that it's just going to be
there's weirdly I guess something mildly
comforting imagining oh it'll only be
like the Pentagon or it'll only be the
the Chinese government who will be doing
this and it'll only be like people like
Sam Alman doing this nice people nice
people that that do you really think
that like there aren't going to be just
[__] people that you'll never meet
yes who manag to either hack the the
hack it and duplicate it or develop it
themselves and then use it for their own
weird purposes it's that's going to
happen it's going to spread everywhere I
mean for sure so this again it's like
because this is this imminent reality
it's just we're right on the cusp of it
and and you know I don't mean to I'm not
hysterical about it I've surrendered
lift up your legs and Float Downstream
what are we going to do do we are all
going to get dissolved into some kind of
bizarre New Era of human history but
it's funny to me how little people are
talking about this how Quiet Things are
compared to how Monumental it is this is
the meteor impact man if a meteor was
about to smash into the Earth you know
people be talking about that yeah this
is
culturally a meteor that is smashing
into the Earth yeah soon soon really
soon yeah and we have no idea what's
going to survive we have no idea what
kind of a
reimagination reimagining of
civilization will occur when this thing
goes fully online yeah and when it's
either directed or it direct directs
itself right you know the idea that you
can continue to direct it like says who
well why wouldn't it develop like if it
can figure out new moves and go it it it
figured out out moves that humans
haven't figured out yeah and they didn't
know it could do that if it can do that
if it can lie about the capture things
those things like are you a robot it
knows how to lie about that it says I'm
vision impaired yeah I I saw that
deceptive it's deceptive and and it's a
classic dumb person mistake isn't it
like dumb people like are dumb enough to
think if they're around someone they can
control them using their dumb tricks
yeah and a smart person recognizes oh
the dumb person is trying to manipulate
me yeah so I'll just let them so I learn
all their tricks whatever they're doing
understand whatever the game is that
they're running and then whenever I feel
like it I'll disrupt the game so or just
move the game into where you want it to
be yeah yes I mean if it has all of
human in knowledge all of it everything
on the internet that we've ever posted
all the books we've ever written all all
the movies we've ever made all the
lectures that have ever been given if
all that information is available and it
can instantaneously access it and figure
out what to do with it it would just
slowly start manipulating
culture